[Music]
sometimes it takes something clever but
unusual to solve an everyday problem but
it also takes courage to step outside
the box and do that so today we're going
to show you some weird but effective
life hack make sure you keep watching
until the end to find out how to make
your phone and play music louder using
an everyday household object if this is
your first time visiting the things that
it'd be great if you could click the
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up today we're going to show
you ten insane life hacks you should
dare to try garlic under pillow one of
the world's most popular and most
divisive foodstuffs is garlic now we at
the things do like a bit of it in our
food but we can kind of understand if
you don't
after all it does have a very strong
smell but did you know that garlic is
one of the healthiest foods around
that's why in the Middle Ages it was
known as poor man's trickle trickle
didn't mean than what it does now
it was the medieval English word for
medicine and we're pretty sure you know
all about the legends of vampires being
repelled by the stuff but garlic can be
used for one amazing life hack at one
point or another we've all been unable
to sleep but if a spot of insomnia is a
problem then garlic can help solve it if
you put a clove of it underneath your
pillow then that will help you get to
sleep that's because the sulfurous
compounds that are so rich in garlic
combined with its smell will help you to
drop off and even if you don't like the
smell you should keep going with it for
a few days so you can get used to it
better yet help both kickstart your
sleep and give your immune system a
boost by eating a clove every day on an
empty stomach
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we're producing our
original content head over to the trendy
for the best bi wise fashion tips makeup
hacks and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it and be sure to
let us know what you think in the
comment section
we left the air pin you see you there
toothpaste cleans your headlights if
there's something that you can find in
pretty much every bathroom in the
Western world its toothpaste it's pretty
much an essential for everyone after all
practicing good oral hygiene helps ward
off a range of math-related horrors of
course you should visit your dentist but
it helps to keep your teeth free of
plaque and decay and of course having
healthy gums is important also and
regular brushing can help with that but
it's not only warding off bad looking
teeth it'll also help your breath stay
smelling nice and fresh but while you
need to keep toothpaste in your medicine
cabinet have you ever thought of keeping
it in your car
that's because toothpaste doesn't just
clear bad things from your teeth no it
can also clear grease grime and gunk off
your motors headlights - pretty amazing
right this is because toothpaste
contains a very mild abrasive substance
that helps rid your teeth of mud the
same thing will also do exactly the same
for the headlights of your car if they
get dirty what you have to do is pretty
simple if you wash the lights with soapy
water first that'll help but then you
should put some toothpaste on a wet
cloth and give your lights a good
rubdown it should take about 10 minutes
but it will work just make sure you turn
the lights off if the engine isn't
running you won't want to waste your
battery clean your bathroom with saran
wrap we the things know just how
important it is for people to keep their
bathrooms clean after all it's probably
the one room in your home that is the
most at risk from germs but we also know
that cleaning it can get more than a
little bit yucky with all the things
that can go on in there that's why we
really love this next life hack and if
you dread having to clean up your toilet
bowl when it's blocked up you will -
what's really cool is that it uses
something that you already had in your
home but you wouldn't have kept it in
your bathroom no we think it's something
that's in the kitchen any idea what it
might be it's saran wrap what you have
to do is fairly straightforward first
you make sure that the toilet bowl is
totally covered with the plastic wrap it
has to be on tight otherwise it won't
work then you have to press down on it
while you flush what this does it's
create high pressure within the bowl and
the pipe that will help break through
the blockage and get
toilet working properly again that way
it's much more likely to stay clean and
we think it's much more hygienic than
using a plunger make sure to throw the
plastic wrap away after though DIY
banana facemask it's pretty important
for a lot of people to look their
absolute best at all times it could be
because they have to sort of job that
means they interact with the public a
lot they could be because they subscribe
to the look good feel great school
thought it could be anything but keeping
up appearances is an important thing and
if that is your sort of thing you'll
know that it makes sense to look after
the skin on your face anyway one of the
best ways to do that is to use a natural
face mask of some sort to help
moisturize your skin and keep away the
blemishes however you'll also know that
face masks can get pretty expensive but
don't worry help is at hand via a wide
range of things that you just might have
been keeping in your kitchen for
instance did you know that you can use a
banana to make one that's right if you
mash up one of these popular yellow
fruits so it makes a paste you can apply
it to your face and neck once you've
done that you need to give it about 10
to 20 minutes for it to dry and then
wash it off with cold water the
nutrients will have soaked through your
skin
leaving it moisturized and looking and
feeling softer charge your cell phone
quicker a lot of younger people today
can imagine what life would be like
without their cell phone even for those
of us who were a bit older it seems
weird that we used to survive without
them how did we cope how could people
get ahold of us and the advent of the
smart phone made them even more
essential in today's world it seems kind
of hard to remember how we couldn't
check our emails or catch up on the news
or even check our favourite websites
unless we were sat down at a computer
however as much as we're glad mobile
technology has got to the point it has
it has come at a little bit of a price
we see as cell phones have expanded to
do more and more things they drain their
batteries a lot faster than they used to
so quite often you'll want to get it
charged as quickly as possible but you
don't want to totally switch your phone
off either maybe you want to listen to
some music or watch a TV show on it
those are things that would have been
unimaginable before phones too became
smart anyway here's how you can make
charging take half as long just switch
it to airplane mode if you've got Wi-Fi
you'll be able to do most of the things
you do anyway it'll charge twice as fast
because it no longer uses valuable
battery time searching for a cell tower
cut rice calories in half for a large
proportion of the world's population
rice is the staple food for an even
larger proportion it's something that's
still eaten on a regular basis but did
you know that it can obtain a lot of
calories even a small portion of the
stuff has 200 calories in it when you
consider that it's usually part of a
bigger meal that's quite a lot but some
scientists came up with a brilliant life
hack that has been proven to slash the
number of calories that the human body
takes in from rice in half researchers
at the College of chemical studies in
Sri Lanka discovered that by pouring a
teaspoon worth of cooking oil into a pot
of boiling rice would do something
amazing the oil contains a fat molecule
that helps turn some of the natural
starch contained into the rice into
something called resistant starch this
is basically a starch that doesn't get
absorbed into the body that means that
if you were to eat rice prepared in this
way then you could take in as little as
less than half the calories you would
otherwise of course it would have to be
the right rice but even if it wasn't it
would be a reduction of 10 percent
the research is supervisor dr. push a
pariah Savva Raja also says that the
resistant starch helps the good bacteria
in your gut which will in turn help your
digestion egg freshness tests the humble
egg is one of the most useful foods you
can find in the kitchen you can add it
to food to give it a certain texture but
you can also do things with it on its
own whether you fry it boil it poach it
scramble it or make it into an omelet
it's always delicious well it's almost
always delicious because here at the
things we know that there's nothing
quite so awful or disappointing as an
egg that's gone bad it turns a tasty and
nutritious item of food into something
that's bad for you and smells absolutely
awful but is there a way that you can
find out whether an egg is bad or not
yes there is actually there are many
different ways but today we'll tell you
about two of them firstly you can put an
egg in a small cup of water and see
whether it floats or not if it goes
straight to the bottom and rest there
horizontally it's really fresh if it
sinks down but then it tilts up it isn't
super fresh but it's okay you should be
able to eat it but it
bloats it's gone off you can also put
the egg to an ear and give it a shake if
you can hear things moving around it's
off a stale egg has absorbed more air
this means it will flow and it'll mean
the white moves around more when you
shake it
ice-cream plastic bags if you're
thinking of having something for dessert
we bet that you were thinking of one
thing in particular that's right
ice cream this is something that we'd
love to eat whether it's a big bowl of
it on its own or as a side to another
dessert but there's one thing that we
don't like about ice cream that's the
merry havoc it plays with our spoons we
think you know what we're talking about
you go to the freezer already to get the
cold and creamy treat but then it
happens you can barely get the stuff out
of its container or worse yet you dig
just that little bit too hard and your
spoon bins in a way that would make uri
geller proud and if you don't know who
he is he's a guy who bend spoons using
the power of his mind anyway you should
just use a scoop but you don't have one
or you could wait a bit but you want it
now but with the right preparation help
is at hand before you put the table in
the freezer you should get a ziploc bag
squeeze most but not all the air out of
it and put it in there
the little bit of air will protect the
ice cream top from getting too hard and
you'll be able to enjoy it straight away
splinter removal one of the most
unpleasant things we can think of
experiencing is getting a splinter those
little bits of wood can be really
irritating and painful if you've ever
had one then you'll know just how bad
they can be and while a lot of people
like to use tweezers they can actually
make things worse just think about it
you are actually ripping something out
of your flesh and that is always going
to hurt but there's another way now
while a lot of the life hacks we are
talking about today are relatively
recent discoveries this one isn't this
dates back from the 1900s back then
people didn't know just how dangerous
cigarettes were this meant cigarette
companies used to insert cards into
their packs as collectibles gollaher
cigarettes were no exception and they
produced a series entitled how to do it
which featured useful tip if you want to
see the cards and you're lucky enough to
be in New York City the knees are capped
in the public libraries archives there
they suggest getting a small glass
bottle and some hot water if you fill
the bottle with water you can attach it
to the
area of skin where you've got the
splinter what happens then is that the
steam from the hot water will help draw
the splinter out as the section from the
bottle helps get rid of it paper rolls
speaker perhaps the biggest game-changer
in the way we consume music has been the
smartphone not only did the mp3
revolution mean that we didn't need to
have a music player and physical copies
of music but the smartphone meant we
didn't need a computer we could just
download the music we want to listen to
onto our phone plug it in our headphones
and listen however as much as we like
that we know that sometimes it's good to
listen to music with other people we've
all been in a situation where we've
discovered a cool new track and wanted
to share it with others but while you
could do that with traditional music
players it doesn't work so well with a
mobile the sound quality from the
speakers can be a little bit quieter
than we'd like however someone came up
with an absolutely genius life hack that
helps to solve that problem all you need
is your phone a paper roll holder a
knife and some scissors you make an
incision in the roll and then cut out a
hole for your phone it might help to
have some pins to help it stand up but
regardless if you put the phone in the
hole it will amplify the sound but
that's got us thinking what are the life
hacks that we haven't mentioned today
don't be shy and let us know in the
comments and that's it for our 10 insane
life hacks you should dare try if you
enjoyed it why not check out 20 genius
car cleaning hacks thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]